Olá meus amigos minhas amigas boa noite
sejam bem-vindos para mais uma live Boa
noite elía e
Carlos hoje nós vamos discutir três
artigos e responder as dúvidas de vocês
que vocês deixaram documento e as
dúvidas ao
vivo bem o primeiro ar queria discutir
com vocês é um assunto interessante é se
a
diet pelo DNA aet
através de exam de DNA se ela é superior
ou não a dieta convencional para o
controle da glicos para controle do
diabetes do pré-diabetes
então Vamos explorar essa pesquisa e
descobrir se a dieta personalizada ela é
superior ou não então um estudo recente
investigou se a dieta personalizada
baseada no DNA supera a dieta
tradicional para melhorar o controle
glicêmico em pessoas com pré-diabetes
o estudo analisou a mudança dos níveis
de glicose em jejum após se semanas além
de outros resultados como tolerância
glicos hemoglobina glicada composição
corporal lipídios no sangue que são as
gorduras e pressão arterial então o
estudo contou com a participação de 148
pessoas com pré-diabetes
idade média de 59 anos maioria mulheres
asiáticas Então os participantes foram
divididos em três grupos um grupo
recebeu a aconselhamento alimentar
padrão o outro recebeu aconselhamento
personalizado Com base no DNA e um
terceiro grupo recebeu o mesmo
aconselhamento personalizado mas por
meio de um
aplicativo Então como é que esse estudo
foi conduzido no grupo de dieta
personalizada os pesquisadores coletaram
amostra de saliva e realizaram testes
genéticos para identificar variações
genéticas associadas das doenças
cardiometabólicas Então essas
informações foram combinadas com
diretrizes nutricionais para criar
planos alimentares
individuais os participantes do grupo de
aconselhamento padrão receberam
orientações Gerais de alimentação
saudável Então quais foram os resultados
curiosamente né uma coisa
contraintuitiva a mudança na agricos em
jejum não diferiu significativamente
entre os grupos de dieta personalizada e
o grupo de aconselhamento padrão no
entanto alguns resultados secundários
como níveis de glicose pós-prandial e
hemoglobina glicada mostraram pequenas
melhorias no grupo de dieta
personalizada mas é importante ressaltar
que esses resultados precisam ser
interpretados com cautela então a diet
personalizada também conhecida como
nutrição de precisão parte do princípio
cada pessoa é única e responde de forma
diferente a mesma nutrição e a Teoria é
que a dieta personalizada levando em
conta informações como genética
microbioma intestinal e resposta
glicêmica individual poderia ser mais
eficaz do que as recomendações genéricas
de alimentação
saudável então analisando o conjunto de
estudos anteriores embora alguns estudos
sugiram que a dieta personalizada pode
ser melhor pode ter mais benefícios as
evidências ainda são limitadas em
inclusivas um estudo de 2023 não
encontrou diferenças significativas na
hemoglobina glicada entre a dieta
personalizada e a dieta padrão em
pessoas com pré-diabetes ou diabetes
tipo do outro estudo de 2021 mostrou uma
redução maior na hemoglobina glicada no
grupo de dieta personalizada mas esse
resultado pode ter sido influenciado por
outros fatores como a menor ingestão de
carboidratos nesse GR então concluindo a
dieta personalizada com base no DNA
ainda é um campo em desenvolvimento tem
resultados promissores mas ainda não
totalmente
comprovados e as pesquisas atuais não
fornecem evidências Claras suficientes
para afirmar que a dieta personalizada
apesar de ser muito lógico isso seria
superior à dieta tradicional para
melhorar a saúde no entanto a
individualização da dieta considerando
estilo de vida mais do que a genética né
o histórico médico e preferência
alimentar continua sendo fundamental
para uma saúde ideal então isso bate
muito com minhas percepções eu acredito
que esses exames de genética a gente tem
no mercado hoje eles são limitados
realmente para essa questão é muito
melhor você indicar uma dieta ketoflex
uma dieta cetogênica sensata ou ou carb
para as pessoas em geral do que ficar
tentando realmente personalizar na na
minha experiência isso Bate bastante
hum Apesar que as empresas de exames
genéticos não vão concordar comigo e
provavelmente várias nutricionistas
também não vão concordar comigo
V Vamos pro próximo artigo
aqui vamos falar agora sobre o problema
que afeta milhões de pessoas em todo
mundo que a bexiga imperativa
especialmente as mulheres
né então Muitas pessoas têm esse
problema provavelmente alguns de vocês
já se viram correndo pro banheiro várias
vezes ao
dia e houve um medo de algum acidente de
vocês acabar perdendo
urina no caminho pro banheiro isso pode
ter impedido até você de ter aproveitado
alguma atividade então importante
prestar atenção Nesse artigo o novo
estudo trouxe resultados promissores
sobre um tratamento multicomponente né
com vários pontos para a [ __ ]
hiperativa
e vamos destrinchar os
detalhes agora antes disso Vamos definir
o que que é biga
imperativa essa condição ela é
caracterizada por uma necessidade
urgente incontrolável de urinar mesmo
quando a bexiga não está totalmente
cheia essa urgência incontrolável ela
pode ser tão intensa a ponto de levar a
você perder urina na roupa incontinência
urinária e além dessa urgência correria
aativa também pode aumento na frequência
de Idas ao banheiro durante o dia também
durante a noite e durante a noite a
gente chama isso de nictúria e se a
pessoa perde urina na roupa de cama a
gente chama de enurese noturna né que é
comum em crianças mas pode acontecer em
adultos também então estudo que nós
vamos discutir hoje foi um ensaio
Clínico randomizado considerado padrão
ouro em pesquisas médicas participaram
79 mulheres com idades entre 40 e 80
anos e Eras essas mulheres eram
diagnosticadas com bexiga hiperativa
moderada grave elas foram recrutadas em
quatro clínicas médicas no Japão e
dividida de forma aleatória em dois
grupos um grupo recebeu tratamento
multifatorial
multicompetente multicomponente en
quantra o outro grupo não recebeu
nenhuma intervenção serviram como
controle
então o grupo de tratamento o grupo que
recebeu a intervenção multti fatorial
participou de quatro sessões semanais de
30 minutos cada uma abordando um aspecto
diferente do tratamento Então as
participantes aprenderam a registrar os
seus hábitos urinários então fizeram o
diário miccional registrando a
frequência o volume Episódio de urgência
e incontinência e esse diário esse
registro ajudou a identificar padrões e
gatilhos por
sintomas o segundo passo seria a
cognitivo comportamental as
participantes receberam informações
sobre o funcionamento da bexiga do
sistema urinário além de aprender
técnicas de TCC que é terapia cognitivo
comportamental para lidar com a
ansiedade e o medo relacionado à biga
hiperativa então a TCC também ajudou a
identificar e modificar pensamentos e
comportamentos que pioravam os sintomas
o terceiro ponto é modificação do estilo
de vida as particip receberam
orientações sobre mudanças esse estilo
de vida como reduzir a ingestão de
líquidos e
cafeína ambos podem irritar a bexiga e
piorar os sintomas o quarto ponto é o
treinamento dos músculos do Ário pélvico
as participantes aprenderam o exercícios
para fortalecer a musculatura pélvica
esses músculos do Assoalho sustentam a
bexiga e ajuda a controlar mixão quinto
ponto é o treinamento da bexiga as
participantes foram incentivadas a
aumentar gradualmente
intervalo entre as idas ao banheiro com
objetivo de reeducar Estiga e reduzir a
frequência sexto ponto é prevenção de
Recaídas Então as participantes
aprenderam estratégias para lidar com
situações que poderiam desencadear os
sintomas como estresse e Viagens e
receber apoio psicológico para manter as
mudanças conquistadas ao longo
prazo Então os resultados desse estudo
com essas múltiplas abordagens foram bem
animador o grupo que recebeu o
tratamento
multicomponente apresentou uma melhora
significativa na qualidade de vida
relacionada à saúde medida por um
questionário específico Além disso houve
redução dos sintomas de ansiedade número
de mixões e urgência urinária em
comparação com grupo controle então o
tratamento também mostrou melhora no
sintoma de depressão e na percepção da
gravidade da incontinência embora o
número de episódios de incontinência não
tenha mudado de maneira significativa
então esses resultados mostram a
importância do tratamento comportamental
paraa bexiga hiperativa muitas vezes as
pessoas recorrem apenas a medicamentos
como os anti polinésios H muita boca
seca muita constipação mas as terapias
comportamentais podem ser tão eficazes
quanto os medicamentos sem os efeitos
colaterais Além disso o tratamento
multicomponente oferece uma abordagem
mais completa abordando não apenas o
sintomas físicos mas também os aspectos
emocionais e comportamentais da [ __ ]
imperativa Tá então vamos pro próximo
item próximo
artigo vamos falar entre relação entre
exercícios físicos e a
depressão se você é alguém que você
conhece tá enfrentando a
depressão então Preste bastante atenção
Nesse artigo aqui então analisar os
exercícios físicos para tentar entender
quais seriam esses tipos de exercícios
físicos que são mais eficazes para
ajudar a reduzir um sintomas de
depressão então estudos recentes têm
mostrado resultados promissores em
relação aos benefício do exercício
físico para quem sofre de depressão mas
fica essa pergunta qual que é o melhor
exercício que esse estudo em questão é
que tá tentando responder então essa
meta análise abrangente metanálise para
quem não sabe é aun são de vários
artigos diferentes
analisados através do mesmo método
estatístico então reuniu dados de 218
bastante estudo 200 estudos 218 estudos
ensaios clínicos randomizados com mais
de 14.000 participantes diagnosticados
com depressão investigou os efeitos de
diferentes tipos de exercício na
gravidade dos sintomas depressivos e os
resultados foram
interessantes Praticamente todo todos os
tipos de exercícios físicos analisados
incluindo caminhada corrida yoga
musculação dança ciclismo exercícios
aeróbicos mistos tiveram Impacto
Positivo na redução dos sintomas de
depressão apenas a categoria de
aconselhamento de atividade física geral
que consistia em recomendações sem
acompanhamento não apresentou os
significativos Mas por que que o
exercício físico seria tão poderoso
contra
acredita-se que o exercício físico
estimula a neuroplasticidade que é a
capacidade do nosso cérebro de se
modificar e criar novas conexões neurais
então a depressão pode estar relacionada
a um padrão de pensamento negativo e
repetitivo chamado de
fulminação e ao praticar exercícios
novas conexões neurais podem ser
formadas direcionando nossos pensamentos
para sentimentos e Emoções mais
positivas Além disso o exercício físico
promove a liberação de endorfina um
neurotransmissor que proporciona a
sensação de bem-estar e reduz a dor e
qual que seria a dose ideal de exercício
físico a combater a
depressão a pesquisa também investigou a
intensidade do exercício influencia os
resultados e a resposta é sim exercícios
mais intensos como correr parec ter um
efeito ainda maior do que
caminhar isso sugere que para obter o
máximo de benefícios é importante
encontrar um um nível de intensidade que
seja desafiador sem você se estourar
todo né que seja também prazeroso e
sustentável a longo
prazo e como é que o exercício físico se
compara com outras formas de tratamento
como terapia
cognitivo terapia cognitivo
comportamental TCC medicamentos
antidepressivos como os inibidores de
recaptação da
serotonina Então os resultados mostraram
que em alguns casos o exercício físico
pode ser tão eficaz quanto uma
Sertralina uma paroxetina que são os
inibidores de recaptação da serotonina e
tão eficácias quanto a terapia cognitiva
comportamental na redução dos sintomas
de depressão no entanto é importante
ressaltar que o exercício físico não
substitui o acompanhamento psicológico
nem
médico então é importante encontrar uma
atividade que você gosta de
fazer experimentar
diferentes modalidades até achar alguma
que motive e te dê prazer é importante
Se possível também exercitar-se com
amigos ou em grupo que torna mais
divertido Se for possível e crie
gatilhos mentais também para você poder
fazer atividade física deixa os seus
tênis de corrida por exemplo na porta de
casa para você se
lembrar para você ter um compromisso com
o exercício só um exemplo definir
horários fixos também ajuda bastante né
da prática de atividade física para
poder tornar isso um hábito sempre
comece devagar e aumente gradualmente
isso é muito importante né para você não
se estourar todo existir e celebre as
conquistas né Estabeleça metas reconheça
seus Progressos e quando você atingir
aquela meta intermediária comemore para
que você não perca o
pique Então embora a maioria dos
exercícios físicos tenha se mostrado
eficácia contra
depressão alguns tipos de atividades
Como dança parece ter um efeito ainda
mais pronunciado então se você não quer
fazer nenhuma atividade física Tá aí uma
boa dica a dança pode ser uma
alternativa para
você é importante encontrar uma
atividade que você gosta e se encaixa na
sua
rotina bem vamos
lá vamos responder as perguntas aqui do
documento Boa noite Eliseu Liane Carlos
e Denise
hã vamos dividir a tela
B gente começa do começo né que eu tô
aqui nossa tem 31 perguntas hoje vez que
eu chequei tinha 20 Nossa Senhora não
devia ter falado três artigos não devia
ter ficado só em dois vamos
lá primeira pergunta ten um vtil
gostaria de saber sua opinião sobre
protetores Solares orais
tem algum risco à saúde são eficientes
ter algum para
recomendar protetores Solares orais eles
são conhecidos como nutricosméticos ou
fotoprotetores orais né eles têm ganhado
popularidade como uma forma de proteção
contra os danos causados pelo sol eles
não substituem totalmente o filtro solar
ou bloqueador solar porém eles contém
ingredientes como antioxidantes extratos
de plantas podem aumentar a resistência
da pele aos danos
Solares Então vamos discutir uns aqui o
polipódio leucotomos é um estrap lambaia
e tem propriedades antioxidantes
antiinflamatórias estudos mostram que o
polipódio pode reduzir a
intensidade do vermelhidão né do eritema
induzido por ultravioleta e aumentar a
dose mínima de eritema então tem uma
proteção contra queimaduras Solares
então em pacientes com vitiligo o
polipódio tem mostrado o potencial para
melhorar a repigmentação quando
combinado com fototerapia ultravioleta B
de banda estreita então estudos indicam
que combinação do polipódio com a
ultravioleta B de banda estreita pode
aumentar a eficácia tratamento e reduzir
a fototoxicidade Além disso você pode
utilizar vitaminas antioxidantes
vitamina C e e a chantin também isso
pode ajudar a neutralizar os radicais
livres gerados pela exposição
ultravioleta reduzindo o risco de danos
celulares e envelhecimento prematuro e
potencialmente câncer de pele então
utilize também além dos orais utilize os
externos base de tinosorb tá Tino t i n
tinosorb ou tinosorb
em relação ao efeito colateral tem pouco
coisa pode ser desconforto gastro
intestinal pode ser coceira mas é raro
Ok novamente Não substitua os orais
pelos aliás os bloqueadores externos
pelos horar orais são
só utilizados como complemento você pode
utilizar por exemplo marcas recomendadas
heloc elocar né ou heloc que tem um Popó
bomos e o ilum que é outra marca que
contém antioxidantes potentes
recomendada contra a questão da
queimadura e proteção solar
adicional próxima
pergunta Tem alguma vitamina complexo b
que teria que ter mais cuidado com a
dose tenho visto vários suplementos e as
concentrações variam muito
o que tenho comprado a vitamina B1 B5 B6
tem 100 mg de cada e B9 800
MG então das vitaminas do complexo
B em geral elas são seguras Mas você tem
que tomar um cuidado especial com a
vitamina B6 a piridoxina porque o
consumo excessivo de B6 pode levar
neuropatia sensorial que dá fraqueza
muscular alterações orais e a taxia que
é falta de coordenação de movimentos a
B1 também com exceção de pessoas que têm
doença de paxon que pode usar doses bem
altas em pessoas normais elas podem
causar efeitos colaterais como
convulsões queda da frequência
respiratória e vaso dilatação
periférica Ok então essas duas vitaminas
B1 e B6 que tem que prestar mais atenção
agora eu tô acreditando que você colocou
errada a dose aí não deve ser 100 mg de
B6
né Tá mas se for dá uma reduzida aí
tá próxima pergunta
nessa semana serão lançadas as TVs no
mercado brasileiro elas prometem
eliminar a luz azul além das outras
vantagens como esse será um sonho de
consumo massivo pergunto se é uma boa
opção ou fica a sugestão para abordar
esse assunto bem esse é um assunto que
eu não tava por dentro não eu dei uma
pesquisada tá a cerveza laser então
estão ganhando realmente popularidade no
Mercado Global estão sendo lançadas no
Brasil prometem várias vantagens
incluindo a eliminação da luz
azul Então vamos falar aí das potenciais
vantagens e desvantagens uma das
vantagens é o tamanho da tela que parece
telas maiores com essa tecnologia de 100
a 150
polegadas por um custo aparentemente
menor as TVs tradicionais
a de imagem aparentemente é melhor com
cores mais vivas e
precisas e tem mais mais
realistas parece que também essa
tecnologia leva a maior durabilidade da
TV levando uma vida última mais
[Música]
longa Parece que elas são mais fáceis de
transportar e de
instalar vem também com recurso de
Android TV aplicativo de streaming isso
aí já é uma idade para qualquer TV atual
né mas
desvantagens aparentemente ela sofre
mais interferência de Luz Ambiente então
a qualidade da imagem pode ser afetado
Pela Luz
Ambiente então teria que ficar mais
escuro o ambiente onde tá essa TV parece
tem um preto menos intenso do que
[Música]
OLED Parece que elas tem uma latência
maior o que pode atrapalhar para quem
gosta de jogo parece que a instalação é
mais
complexa e tem essa promessa de
eliminação da luz
azul só que isso daí não é certeza
absoluta tá pessoal a gente vai ter que
ver na prática isso
daí vamos ver na prática se realmente
essa tecnologia vai
reduzir a luz
azul tinha uma pergunta também não sei
se alguém retirou essa
pergunta mas eu vou eu vou falar aqui na
tela porque não sei porque que essa
pergunta sumiu era uma pergunta da
progesterona bem
a pergunta era se teria algum benefício
usar progesterona sem estrog Só que essa
pergunta fo repetida da semana passada
porque eu já respondi ela na Live
anterior porque a pessoa no caso teve
que suspender o estrogênio B idêntico
devido a desconforto nas mamas e eu
falei na Live anterior né que tem
benefício sim de usar progesterona
isoladamente
porque a progesterona vai aliviar alguns
dos sintomas vasomotores como ondas de
calores suores noturnos que são comuns
na
menopausa vai melhorar a qualidade do
sono vai atuar no sistema nervoso
central Protegendo o cérebro ajudando na
cognição nas emoções tem ação
antidepressiva se a pessoa tiver útero
vai melhorar também o endométrio
Protegendo o endométrio de hiperplasia e
câncer
Então hoje em dia a gente prefere usar
progesterona vi oral por conta desse
efeito gaba que ele tem no sono de
melhorar o
sono é ideal usar progesterona bida na
forma
micronizada Ok mas eu já falei isso na
semana passada
também pessoal que não tá acompanhando
ao vivo assistam as lives anteriores por
favor tá
eh costumo ingerir suplementos
hidrossolúveis com água contendo sal
rosa do himala entretanto algumas lives
atrás você disse que o zinco disputa
absorção com magnésio cobre o ferro se
se não me engana o sal rosa Himalaia
possui magnésio com abre ferro nesse
caso quando tomar suplemento zinco com
água devo tomar essa água sem sal sim
deve
Ok Deve
sim quando se trata suplementação com
minerais é importante você entender
interações entre os diferentes
nutrientes para otimizar as interações
entre zinco magnésio cobre e ferro ok
então o zinco e magnésio competem entre
si na absorção do intestino se você for
utilizar é melhor usar em horários
diferentes ou usar fama quelada que
elimina esse problema Ok ou espae o
tempo da ingestão entre um e outro o
zinco e cobre também competem e o zinco
e o ferro também competem o sal rosa
Malá cont temm uma variedade de minerais
como magnésio cálcio potássio c e ferro
tem 80 no total
só que na verdade a grande parte é
cloret de sódio né é mais de 98% é
cloret de sódio só 2% que vai ter esses
80 minerais diferentes
aí então os minerais no sal rosa
Himalaia podem competir sim com os
minerais suplementos D solúveis
então é importante você tomar os
suplementos com água normal ou usar fama
quelada ok
e monitorar também os níveis no no
sangue no laboratório né importante
também se eu tomar um suplemento com
paldarco ácido caprílico alho cravo
enquanto estou tomando SA
buard ele pode matar as cepas do
probiótico também ou não interfere sim
pode de fato interferir no probiótico
porque ele é um probiótico à base de
fungo né o pco ele tem propriedades
anicas o capro também o o cravo então o
uso desses fitoterápicos podem matar ou
anular né o sacom bolard ok então o
ideal é você tomar em momentos
diferentes ou se foi absolutamente
necessário tomar junto você toma os
fitoterápicos no horário e 12 horas
depois toma o sacaro mísseis mas o ideal
é você tomar realmente épocas diferentes
Ok o senhor recomenda fazer despara
tização intestinal de forma natural ou
antiparasitários não teriam muito efeito
colateral então Eu normalmente eu
prefiro utilizar os antiparasitários de
farmácia os sintéticos mesmos daí eu vou
explicar porquê eh na verdade na minha
no meu entendimento os sintéticos não
estão tendo tanto efeito colateral assim
e e a versão natural mais demorado e
mais complexo
tá as vantagens de você fazer uma
despara tização natural com éos e
suplementos como é o caso por exemplo do
áo do Cravinho do absinto da Nogueira é
porque eles vão ter outros benefícios
pro organismo né eles vão ser
antiparasitários são bem
tolerados e também vão ajudar em outras
questões até como antibac ano como
antiviral e também esses protocolos como
o caso da ruda clarque tem outros
benefícios interessantes por exemplo o
uso do asfal pico da silimarina tem
benefícios adicionais Protegendo o
fígado e efeito
antioxidante porém esses protocolos são
mais complexos e mais difíceis de fazer
e são mais demorado também no efeito né
então tem essa desvantagem de eficácia
variável né pode acontecer de não
funcionar às
vezes tem a ver também com a qualidade
do
ingredientes o tempo é mais longo de
tratamento e mais complicado de de fazer
a vantagem sintéticos é eficácia alta
que eu acredito também que sejam poucos
efeitos colaterais gosto muito usar o
bendazol e ver mectina e também a nitas
oxan né eles têm efeito amplo assim
amplo
[Música]
espectro obviamente pode causar efeitos
colaterais de vez em quando como náuseas
vômitos dor abdominal diarreia ou até
mesmo reações alérgicas e elevação das
enzimas hepáticas mas na prática não
tenho visto isso acontecer
tá então são
muito pragmático em relação a isso daí
mas eu não tenho nada contra o protocolo
da rud CL preferir ela pode
utilizar Quando se usa beberina existe a
necessidade de repor vitamina B não é
essa necessidade da B12 é com a
metiformina tá não tem estudos que eu
tenha encontrado que a beberina também
depleta a vitamina
B12 então no caso você poderia utilizar
a beberina sem expopar em reped tá
al tá pergun aqui meio complicada vou
ver se eu consigo responder também
a forma como
escreveu ficou meio difícil de ler mas
vamos
[Música]
lá meu esposo tem a taxia cerebelar teve
uma atrofia acentuada no cerebelo desde
2016 tem 51 anos é acompanhado pela
Unicamp que ainda não descobriu a causa
tudo começou com a ingestão acidental de
um copo de 200 ml de óleo diesel comecei
a dar ácido Alfa lipóico a ele estou
administrando 10000 MG ao dia dividido
em duas vezes devido a um artigo que L
da
emsp amigos múltiplos para
esclerose um grupo de pessoas com
esclerose múltipla foi submetido a uma
dosagem 1200 MG de aof falip poico em um
ano teve atrofia do cérebro diminuída em
até
66% o que que eu tenho a dizer sobre
isso Devo continuar dando esse
suplemento ao meu esposo como eu faço
para marcar uma consulta posso dar
também ao meu esposo ldn de baixa
dosagem juntamente com o as al falip
poico para o ldn Eu preciso de uma
receita Espero que o senhor me responda
lógo Eu vou responder tô aqui para isso
ok tornei-me membro do grupo pois
preciso dessas respostas que você não
Pure fora assim V responder isso né você
continue no
grupo bem vamos lá A taxia cerebelar é
uma condição complexa e debilitante que
pode ter várias causas pode ser
intoxicação como é o caso aí
aparentemente do seu
esposo deficiências nutricionais doenças
degenerativas o tratamento ele é
multidisciplinar e pode incluir
medicamentos suplementos e Terapi de
reabilitação o alfa lipoico é um
antioxidante potente temo sendo estudado
por seus efeitos neuroprotetores
antiinflamatórios ele pode ser benéfico
em várias condições neurológicas Como o
próprio Alzheimer paxon e a taxia
cerebelar e a esclerose múltipla então
estudos indicam que o alfal lipoico pode
ajudar a reduzir o stresse oxidativo
melhorar a função mitocondrial em
pacientes com esclerose múltipla dose de
até 1200 MG por dia mostraram reduzir a
atrofia cerebral em até 66% ao longo de
um ano não sei se é esse estudo que você
tava falando mas o que eu achei foi em
relação à esclerose
múltipla a dosagem rafal lipoico pode
ser entre 300 A 600 MG por dia acima de
600 MG pode afetar a função tiroidiana
Então tem que ficar de olho nisso mas em
casos específicos como é o caso do teu
marido pode aumentar a dose pode ser até
1800 MG por dia ok Apesar de ser uma
dose alta e tem que estar monitorando
tireóide Então essa dose de 1400 MG você
tá utilizando ela é segura tá dentro do
intervalo seguro mas tem que monitorar
efeitos colaterais como dor de estômago
diarreia e Hipoglicemia o ldn também
ajuda bastante em condições autoimunes e
neurodegenerativas eu uso até a
prevenção de Alzheimer e passo para os
pacientes
também tem propriedades imunomoduladoras
antiinflamatórias
tem estudos mostrando benefícios em
pacientes com esclerose múltipla
fibromialgia e outras doenças
autoimunes a dose entre 3 A 4,5 MG por
dia então você pode sim associar o palip
poico ao ldn Sem problema nenhum tá
continue a suplementar o áo al falip
poico e introduza axona de baixo na
dosagem agora em relação à receita você
vai ter que pegar mesmo a receita porque
senão você não vai conseguir
comprar mas tem que fazer o
acompanhamento ar com médico para
agendar a consulta
comigo você pode entrar em contato com o
número
9713 13 12 eu vou escrever aqui
na nas mensagens
tá ok
vamos pra próxima tem muita pergunta
hoje aqui podem haver outras causas para
a salivação excessiva repentina além de
refluxo problemas neurológicos
construção das vias aéreas superiores os
medicamentos ou problemas
dentários sim além do refluxo
gastroesofágico problemas neurológicos
obstrução das vias aéreas uso de
medicamento e problemas dentários pode
existir ainda outras causas para
salivação excessiva infecções na boca
como cares egite periodontite Afra e
cachumba é uma
causa doenças sistêmicas eh no caso tem
algumas doenças que podem afetar a
salivação e reduzir essa liação como é o
caso da C de jogr mas a doença apesar de
reduzir aação
pode provocar também salivação excessiva
Em alguns momentos em alguns Episódios
além do refluxo outras condições também
como gastroparesia que acontece no
diabético pode estar relacionado a
salivação excessiva a gravidez também é
uma causa de
salivação no primeiro trimestre devido a
alterações hormonais alergias
nasais podem causar aumento na produção
de saliva é uma rinite intoxicação com
certas toxinas como veneno de répteis e
cogumelos podem causar
salivação resfriados infecções
respiratórias estímulos mecânicos táteis
térmicos e gustativos na boca distúrbios
psiquiátricos como esquizofrenia
depressão ou transtorno
bipolar postura inadequada da cabeça e
do pescoço pode afetar a produção e
manejo da saliva Ok então são essas as
as causas aí nós
comentamos teria algum benefício usar PR
nas que eu já respondi Vamos lá
eh qual seria a dose ideal de ideia na
pós-menopausa entre 10 a 25 MG tá essa
que é a dose ideal eu começaria com 10
mg
e monitorizar no sangue Ok em homem você
Pode fazer 50 mg sem problemas mais em
mulheres entre 10 e 20
MG aí vai melhorar a saúde óssea saúde
muscular saúde imunológica saúde
cerebral
Ok
Ahã quais seriam as macas T trans
Idêntica então tem várias no mercado tá
Eu geralmente eu passo manipulado ok mas
tem a maca
androgel que é usada na pele tem o
acheron também que é usada na pele tem
as injetáveis que você vai encontrar
tanto a testosterona base que tem que
ser feita semanal quanto o cipionato de
testosterona E tem também os est de
testosterona que fora o cipionato Você
tem o enantato tem o propionato que é
mais raro aí você tem um decanoato eles
não são exatamente bioidênticos mas eles
são ligados a ésteres que aumentam a a
meia vida da
testosterona para o homem de 45 anos 100
kg 300 nanog por dcil eu começaria
usando aproximadamente 50 mg
ah de testosterona na pele vi idêntico
tá transdérmico e depois ajustaria a
dose de acordo com a resposta e com os
níveis tanto na saliva quanto no sangue
Ok injetável a dose é por volta de 100
mg por semana tá se você fizer injetável
o cipionato de testosterona ou a
testosterona base também injetável
é lógo que tem que fazer monitoramento e
ver os efeitos colaterais possíveis que
pode ser acne apneia do sono aumento de
próstata alterações de colesterol
né então inchaço Então tem que tá
monitorando isso
daí a vacina para herp zóster é a mesma
para herp simples não porque são doenças
diferentes tá o herp zóster é provocado
pelo vírus da Varela que é o mesmo da
catapora e o herp simples é provocado
pelo vírus herp Simplex tá é a mesma
família de herps vírus mas são vírus
diferentes tá
e no FP simples Você tem o hsv1 e o HS
hsv2 a vacina mais comum paraisos é a
shingrix
ela é uma vacina eficaz mas eu não faria
porque tem relatos de complicações
neurológicas dessa vacina em meninas
adolescentes
tá e não há vacina atual para és um ou
és do simples tá então a vacina que você
conhece é para EPS ó o pro vírus
varicelas
zó então apes do shingrix ter uma
eficácia muito alta tem esse risco aí de
neuropatia então eu não
faria vamos pra
próxima quais seri as causas para
ardência no pênis e dou nos testículos
para
urinar então a dência no pênis pode ser
doença sexualmente transmissível por
exemplo Clamídia gonorreia e sífilis ou
herpes eles podem causar ardência no
pênis na uretra durante a mixão então
você pode ter essas situações aí de DST
dentro da uretra infecções por fungo
também candidíase tanto na cabeça do
pênis quo na uretra pode causar
vermelhidão sensibilidade secreção e
ardência infecções urinárias né que é
mais comum em mulher né como Cistite Mas
é possível em homens de mais idade podem
causar dens a urinar sensação de peso na
bexiga e vontade frequente de
urinar também frequência não frequência
desculpa fricção na cueca ou durante a
masturbação pode causar ardência no p
devido ao atrito reações alérgicas
também com produtos como gel de banho
cremes aplicados na região íntima dor
nos
testículos podem ser provocados por
inflamação infecciosa no
testículo que geralmente são provoc
bactérias ou pela cachumba n da cachumba
também pode ser causa de dor tes
que é inflamação na próstata que pode
levar dor a urinar dor testicular dor
abdominal dor peica febre dor perineal
também e pedra nos ins também pode
provocar dor nos testículos tá e
confundir que achar que a dor no
testículo mas a dor vem da pedra e
hérnia também né que é muito comum pode
causar dor testicular
tá tá Dá f é indicado para hiperplasia
prostática sim é indicado porque ela
pode ter um efeito Além de ela aumentar
a ereção através da inibição da
fosfodiesterase 5 né que ajuda a
aumentar o óxido nítrico e relaxar a
musculatura dos copos C venosos para
entrar sangue el também pode ajudar a
relaxar a bexiga e a próstata melhorando
A mixão
tá e a dose 5 mg por dia de Tad lafila
para esse
fim ingerir açúcar industrializados
ingerir pouca água pode dar dor de
cabeça sem dúvida com
certeza o consumo excessivo de Açúcar
pode levar Picos e quedas né aquele
montanha russa o dia inteiro na glicose
e na insulina isso pode dar dor de
cabeça a retirada da brupa de Açúcar em
pessoas viciadas também pode dar dor de
cabeça e alterações de
humor alimentos processados carnes
processadas tem nitratos nitritos que
podem tambm dar dor de cabeça o
glutamato monossódico em alimentos
industrializados também e a desidratação
é uma causa comum de dor de cabeça tá
quando o corpo não recebe água
suficiente pode dar essa situação aí é
muito importante você beber bastante
água
ok uma pessoa que consome beberina pode
ao mesmo tempo ingerir vinagre de maçã
sim pode tá não tem problema de baixar
demais o açúcar no sangue isso é muito
raro de acontecer tá Teoricamente é
possível mas é muito difícil eu nunca vi
por exemplo isso acontecer eu acho que é
muito interessante você sim associar a
beberina com vinagre de maçã e se por
acaso tiver hipoglicemia porque tá na
hora de você tirar os outros remédio de
diabetes
Lembrando que a beberina não é só útil
para baixar o açúcar mas também baixar
trigliceridos É bem interessante a
beberina além tem ação antiinflamatória
e
antioxidante então o risco de
hipoglicemia vai acontecer se você tiver
utilizando também outros remédios em
conjunto Mas se acontecer você
simplesmente suspende os outros remédios
e fica só com a beberina e o vinagre de
maçã a beberina pode interagir com
remédios para
hipertensão arterial tá então já
aconteceu comigo de paciente tomar
beberina e dá um pico
hipertensivo Em algumas
situações tem um cisto na perna de menos
de meio cm Se não me engano ele baixou e
depois voltou a
crescer da cor da pele mesmo não Costa
Fui ao médico ele falou que é só tirar
não é
perigoso o que o doutor tem a dizer
significa que o organismo está inflamado
então isso pode ser um cisto Sebá pelo
que você tá descrevendo ou
uma situação como a
lipoma e não necessariamente é informção
sistêmica tá
eu acho que você pode tirar com
segurança isso
daí agora é bom você fazer uma análise
também se você tem inflamação
sistêmica Apesar de que o cisto ou o
lipoma não necessariamente indica que
você está inflamado de forma
generalizada
Ok geralmente é uma cirurgia simples se
não tiver muito aprofundado no seu
organismo então eu recomendo que você
faça a retirada sim tá
lá no vídeo você disse que 80% das
Pedras é
Oxalato 10% é ácido úrico 5% ácido úrico
puro 10% das Pedras está ligado à
infecção e 1% é
cistina
Ah você já disse numa outra Live que
magnes citrato previne a formação de
pedras a minha dúvida é se previne todos
esses tipos de pedras Não não é bem
assim não
cálculo de Oxalato de cálcio por
exemplo ele deve ser combatido com muo
ingestão de água e uma dieta baixa em
Oxalato você tem que eliminar os
alimentos que sejam rico em Oxalato em
alguns casos que pode ser por exemplo
chocolate e muitas vezes tá também
ligado à ingestão insuficiente de
líquidos e alguns casos vão tá ligado
com o hipercalciúria Então tem que ver o
cálcio na urina né Se tiver
hipercalciúria também uma solução é usar
diurético tiazídico de baixa dosagem
para baixar o cálcio na urina o ccio por
exemplo da
Hidroclorotiazida cálculo de ácido úrico
você tem que fazer uma dieta baixa em
purinas tá reduzir carne peixe e aves e
o e por exemplo alimentos
industrializados como alimentos que
tenham xarope de milho de alta frutos
que vira ácido
úrico e também beber bastante água então
tem essa dieta baixa em Purina beber
bastante água e cortar os alimento
processando cálculo deita tem a ver com
infecção do trato urinário Então muitos
casos tem que fazer uso de antibióticos
prolongados tá cálculo de cistina É
muito raro 1%
só e é causado por uma condição
hereditária chamada cistinúria
e nesses casos
é hidratação bastante
intensa e na verdade o méo de consumo de
magnésio vai servir para ir para 85 90%
de cas Tá mas não vai servir para todos
os casos
a atividade física também bastante
importante para prevenir
pedra você disse no vídeo que a
alimentação rica em cálcio não aumenta
as chances de pedra nos INSS pergunto
Mas não é verdade que o sal refinado
aumenta a concentração de cálcio que por
sua vez aumenta a pedra nos
rins porém Ô Eliseu a relação entre
consumo de cálcio sal refinado e a
formação de cálculos urinários é
complexo envolve vários fatores
tá é importante ter um consumo adequado
de cálcio na dieta e geralmente ele não
aumenta o risco de fumação de Pedras
pelo contrário o calci pode até ajudar a
prevenir a a formação de cálculos de
Oxalato de cálcio pois o cálcio liga a
Oxalato no intestino impedindo a
absorção e a excreção posterior pelos
ins então a restrição de cálcio na dieta
pode paradoxalmente aumentar o risco de
formação de
pedras porque se você restringir cálcio
mais Oxalato vai estar disponível para
ser absorvido e excretado na urina
entendeu o sal refinado é um fator de
risco o consumo excessivo pode aumentar
a excreção de cálcio na urina
isso ocorre porque o sódio e o cálcio
compet pelos mesmos mecanismos de
reabsorção nos INSS então quando há
muito sódio na dieta mais cálcio é
secretado na urina aumentando o risco de
formação de
pedras tá
então você tem que ter uma ingestão
adequada de cálcio e tomar cuidado com
excesso de
sódio essa que é a questão
e usar um sal integral no lugar do sal
refinado
[Música]
né sobre a do perun medicina integrativa
tem alternativa sim você pode utilizar
ozônio é uma alternativa o a injeção de
gás do ozônio dentro do das placas de
pironi pode ajudar bastante
tá você pode utilizar com enema que10 os
tocotrienois que é a forma mais ativa da
vitamina e extrato semente de uva são
tratamentos interessantes que podem
ajudar então basicamente isso daí que
seria adicional a medicina tradicional
que pode utilizar medicamentos como
cicina vitamina eox filina inão de
colagenase verapamil ou interferon Alfa
2B também na medicina convencional
utilizar terapias de ondas de choque no
pênis tá pode parecer até engraçado mas
é um tratamento que tá bem vogga nos
últimos anos pode ser utilizado também
dispositivo de tração né tração peniana
que geralmente é usado para aumentar o
pênis mas pode ajudar também no Peroni
em casos mais grav a cirurgia a mais
comum é a cirurgia de plicatura de
nesbit ou de enxerto
is aqui Eu já
respondi alguns vídeos no YouTube ensina
a fazer desodorante natural tem nenhuma
toxina também Vi marcas de desodorante
que alegam ser 100%
natural você indica uma marca de
desodorante natural já pronta para
comprar então eu passo pros pacientes
uma lista de de links Tá eu vou colocar
aqui para você também
deixa eu selecionar
aqui pera aí V ter que fazer
aqui Vou colocar aqui para você aqui tá
uma lista de desodorantes naturais aqui
tá eh não vai aparecer bem
aqui mas tá no no bate-papo aí
tá tá aí no
bate-papo eu vou colocar também no
WhatsApp coloquei no WhatsApp também
para ficar mais fácil de ler tá
a hoje vocês estão perguntadores hein
hoje todo mundo tomou o mesmo remédio
que o Eliseu toma
né Vocês estão perguntadores hoje
aí
ã penso que o PSA Total diminuir de
99,93 para 6,92 e 19 meses não pode ser
considerado isoladamente como se o PSA
livre também diminuir pois assim também
diminur a relação entre os dois seria um
diagnóstico
ruim maril você tá raciocinando demais
tá não fica fazendo essas contas aí
super complicada se continuar alto tem
que fazer uma ressonância
multiparamétrica e ver se não tem um
pirat qu ou CCO se tiver p 4 ou c tem
que fazer biópsia tá não fica tentando
fazer 10 contas aí para ess a relação
diminuiu aumentou
tá já explicou que ocasiona aumento
diminuição do PS Total mas e quanto a PS
livre
unicamente o que ocasion aumento ou
diminuição da enzima
PSA não ligado a proteínas
Então tá vamos lá o PSA livre é a fração
do PSA que não está ligada a proteínas
do
sangue o que aumenta o PSA livre é
câncer de próstata e alguns casos de hpb
e também de prostatite O que diminui o
PC livre é um Tratamento
hormonal geralmente para câncer de
próstata cirurgia
prostática e tratamento para
hpb fatores que afetam o PSA livre a
idade o PSA livre aumenta com a idade o
PC livre mais alto em homens
afroamericanos do que
caucasianos a história familiar de
câncer de próstata pode aumentar o PSA
livre obesidade pode aumentar o PSA
livre ok
são esses fatores
aí Existe algum tipo de tratamento para
prostatite crônica que não envolva
antibióticos tem vários tá eu utilizo
bromexina eu utilizo que
cetina eu utilizo
Pig africano Tiga de
oica em relação a tratamentos não vi
oral você pode fazer por exemplo
exercícios de kegel que é um tipo de
fisioterapia pélvica isso mais é para
prostatite crônica não bacteriana e
exercícios também de choque térmico
alternando gelo e calor na região
pélvica Terapi de relaxamento com
meditação
yoga e mais modernamente terapias de ond
de Choque pode ser uma alternativa
também acupultura também pode ser uma
alternativa
Ok Eliseu
suplemento quebra pedra dissolve as
pedras nos índices não ele não dissolve
não ele ajuda só se for bem pequenininha
a pedra Tá mas em outras condições ele
vai ajudar a não agregar os sais que vão
formar a pedra magn citrato elimina as
pedras dos rins não magn citrato também
inibe a agregação dos sais também tá
magne trata impede que as pedras do rins
aumente tamanho sim impede ah ah ao
tomar magnes trata as pedras doin nunca
vão se formar não depende da dieta e se
a pessoa tá hidratada ou
não se uma pessoa com depressão leve
transtorno de ansiedade normalizar o
sono e dormir às 9 horas e
acordar à cinco e ao acordar em jejum
fizeram uma corrida de alta intensidade
de uns quatro
quilômetros todos os
dias e assim normalizar o seu ciclo
cardiano é possível que essa pessoa se
cure desses
problemas sim é
possível não sei se eu entendi
totalmente essa pergunta
aí mas já conversamos né inclusive fo
artigo de hoje né dizendo que a
atividade física pode tratar depressão
né
e a atividade física pode ajudar a
regular o sono
também outras coisas que podem ajudar é
o jejum
intermitente
Ok não tem uma rotina de sono adequado
causa depressão sim pode ser uma causa
de depressão ou a Depressão causa a
rotina de sono sim uma coisa pode causar
outra né é uma vida Mão Dupla Ok eh
depressão pode causar alteração de sono
e sono ruim pode causar
depressão existe pessoas que não podem
tomar café pois prejudica o sono sim
mesmo que seja de manhã sim
metabolizador metabolizadores lentos de
café não podem tomar nem de
manhã quanto tempo demora pro café sair
do organismo em torno de 8 horas tomar
água ajuda diluir os efeitos da cafina
mais apto não não
ajuda você já ou viu falar sobre leopold
de zonde psiquiatra Húngaro criou teste
de
zonde Não nunca ouvi falar vou até dar
uma pesquisada aqui
rápida para parece que é um método de
avaliação da personalidade baseado em
escolhas de fotos de
rosto a teoria do destino familiar di
onde propõe que as pessoas são
influenciadas pelas experiências
comportamentos de seus
ancestrais e que essas influências podem
ser transmitidas através de
gerações onde acreditava que as pessoas
T uma tendência a repetir padrões de
comportamento e escolhas que foram
modeladas pelos
ancestrais mesmo que não sejam
conscientes
disso pode ter a ver com epigenética
essa situação aí dos onde né a gente
sabe que padrões epigenéticos podem ser
transmitidos para as gerações
posteriores T alterações no
DNA pode ser verdade Aí sim mas eu tô
tomando com conhecimento disso
agora vi um
médico falando em um podcast que se um
paciente chega no consultório dele
aparentemente com TDH esse paciente não
tem uma rotina de sono saudável ou seja
tem o ciclo cardiano bagunçado ele tem
que primeiro tratar o sono para depois
tratar depois do diagnóstico
TDH Qual a sua opinião sobre isso
concordo
mas não tem nada que impea de tratar os
dois ao mesmo tempo sono e TDH pode usar
substâncias
naturais rotina de sono eem ciclo cadian
podem simular constantemente TDH se a
pessoa dorme muito mal ela pode ter déf
de atenção sem
dúvida hiperatividade acho que não masão
pode acontecer sim com falta de sono com
certeza
níveis nom de progesteron em mulher
acima de 50 anos Varia muito tá de
laboratório para laboratório tá e a
variação assim também muito grande de
mínimo pro
máximo beberina pode desinflamar dente
pode ajudar sim a
desinflamar como é que eu sei se tive um
sono regenerador você acordou bem
disposto e não fica com sono durante o
dia ou depois do almoço
pode usar também aplicativos de
monitoramento do sono esses que tem
relógio por exemplo ou fazer uma
polissonografia uma pessoa hidratada
sempre tem que te ter urina transparente
não amarelo bem clarinho tá Se tiver
amarela uma única vez significa que a
pessoa não está ingerindo água depende
né se ela tiver desidratada naquele
momento do dia pode ficar a urina escura
mas se ela ficar maior parte do tempo
bem hidratada a urina dela vai ficar
maior parte do tempo cor amarelo palha
ou quase
transparente gente eu vou parar por aqui
tá não tem tanta pergunta ao vivo
hoje que já temos 1 hora e 6 minutos de
Live tá
Eh ó vamos ver isso
aqui
eh eu não lembro qual foi a
circunstância que ele disse isso não
Eliseu Então não vou nem poder te
responder isso porque eu não lembro
disso eu lembro vagamente mas eu não tô
lembrando a
circunstância depende do peso da pessoa
Eliseu tá se for uma pessoa grande mais
de 100 kg eu usaria 5 G se for uma
pessoa de 50 kg 60 kg eu usaria 3
G não eh eu não acredito que vitamina D
isoladamente vai conseguir tratar
depressão não tá tem que ser
multifatorial não eu não acredito que o
protocolo Coimbra seja melor tratamento
para vitiligo Inclusive eu atendi um
paciente ontem com vitiligo e fez
tratamento Coimbra e não adiantou
nada não ele é um alimento prebiótico
não
probiótico eu já comentei isso durante a
Live tá volta o vídeo no ponto que eu
falei da intoxicação
V6 eu comeria com
casca não com esse selo
[Música]
não depende da pessoa Eliseu a pessoa
que não tem nenhum problema
com Toler histamínica pode tomar comer a
oleaginosa
tranquilamente não colocar castanha de
molho não é para absorver melhor
nutriente é para tirar os antinutrientes
depende
Eliseu Cristiane você está na na Live
ainda se você tiver por aí
pode Eliseu eu respondi as suas
perguntas todas tá você volta lá e e vê
de novo a a resposta que eu dei
tá eu vou esperar mais um minuto para
você se manifestar viu
Cristiane Se você não se manifestar vou
encerrar porque essa Live passou do
tempo que eu tava prevendo porque eu
tinha muita pergunta hoje
a marcas de perfume Eliseu Não eu só
conheço marca de desodorante perfume não
é um problema não porque geralmente
perfume é base alcoólica e não tem metal
pesado que eu sabe perfume não tem
problema de
intoxicação Então essa pergunta eu
respondi da Alf lipoico eu acho que deve
usar assim a dose de 1400 MG Tá ok e
coloca o ldn junto e faz o
acompanhamento com médico da minha linha
pode at marcar comigo
tá Não não é isso
Eliseu tem alimento só tem tocoferol e
tem alimento que tem muito pouco
tocotrienol e tem outro que tem
predominância toc Trein como é o caso do
Urucum tá então dá uma olhada na
composição do óleo de pau
de arroz e também de uc que tem
composições diferentes
tá bem pessoal vou encerrar aqui
tá a pergunta do se aquela que você
colocou no documento Eu já respondi tá
então acredito que você não tenha visto
porque essa Live foi bem longa né mas
volta vídeo que você vai ver a
resposta bem pesso obg pela presença de
vocês até a semana que vem abraço a
todos vocês